all right let's get into audience
questions for the week the first one is
related to the cuban protests and and uh
a situation that we've been talking
about there for about 10 days now
david why do some protests get so much
more media attention
than others for example there are
currently protests happening in
guatemala and south africa
and yet we hear nothing about them in
american media but we hear a lot about
cuba why is this so
the the answer there's two different
answers
first there's a sort of a
commercialization of media
uh answer and then there's a political
answer and in the case of cuba it's
actually
a little bit of both but it's it's
absolutely true in the sense that
first let's figure out if the situations
are different in terms of their
uh level of notoriety in cuba we've seen
significant protests as well as serious
crackdowns
many videos getting out of uh cuban
police
federal local police you know variety of
different levels of law enforcement in
cuba
just grabbing people holding signs off
the street
and a significant and serious crackdown
the protests have been related to
mishandling of covid out of control
inflation a collapsing economy lack of
resources lack of food all sorts of
different things
similarly in south africa there have
been at least 32 people killed
in clashes between police and protesters
the
president of south africa ordered
soldiers to the country's two most
densely populated
provinces because crowds were ransacking
retail stores
and the protests were in response to the
jailing of the former president jacob
zuma
and there's it's been significantly
chaotic in south africa
similarly in guatemala there have been
demands for the resignation of the
president
over his mishandling of the coveted
pandemic a shortage of vaccines etc
there were protests there in guatemala
city as well as in other regions
denouncing the president's
uh handling of the situation um demands
for the president
jamatay to step down and
cases are skyrocketing hospitals are
about to collapse
very low vaccination rate significant
chaos in guatemala
but yet we barely hear about those in
american media but we hear about cuba
so what is the explanation uh there
there's really two
one uh the history of u.s
cuban relations is a big part of it
cuban uh circumstances in cuba relate to
so many american political stories
including this
battle over socialism and communism that
the right has been fighting against
communists like joe biden i mean it's
ridiculous right but it's very
useful for the right to talk about cuba
and anything bad that happens in cuba
um there's also a much more important
from a political standpoint
cuban-american population in terms of
its impact
on the results in florida and so
politically
it's a much more useful population you
know
most non-guatemalans aren't super
concerned
about the guatemalan american vote
as a voting bloc in the united states
for the most
and this applies to argentinian
americans like me and right i mean
there's there's just less political
utility mexico
is certainly an interesting one because
of political reasons and cuba is
as well similarly south african
americans not like cuban americans in
terms of a group that
a state can hinge on so in particular
in that context it's logical that we're
hearing more about cuba
than we are about guatemala and south
africa and then there's just like the
straight-up
commercial narrative story which
narrative
is going to make news viewers
tune in the longest and either happy or
angry at someone so that they continue
to share
articles and sort of engage because that
drives ratings and ad revenue
because of the first piece that i
mentioned there's not as much
need or interest in appealing to
guatemalan americans or south african
americans
it's not going to drive ratings it's not
going to drive news revenue
talking about cuba very very much does
and it's a similar question actually to
why do some shootings get more attention
than others
the right loves to say only shootings
of minorities by white people get
attention because that serves
the left the left often points out
that the right in general doesn't want
to talk about shootings
unless the perpetrator is non-white and
it's like very very
clean along racial lines both stories
are
the reality is there's much more to it
there's power dynamics there's wha
was it an officer involved shooting or
was this um
quote civilians but there's also i mean
when you look at how many mass shootings
take place every day there's clearly a
selection bias that's taking place
and it's much similarly oriented along
the same lines two two things one
what will generate interest from the
standpoint of being a news story
and number two which shootings are of
political relevance to either
or both sides and it's a very similar
thing with which
with the story of which protests get
attention there's something i'm missing
in this analysis
there's more to it um guatemala south
africa cuba
certainly let me know i would love to
hear it one of our sponsors is steady md
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do primary care and
they're giving you
50 off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on
your doctor will be available to you by
text phone and video chat
it's not some random doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz and see which doctor is a
perfect fit for you
you'll get 50 percent off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video